an overwhelming majority of MVPs  approved the eu-us deal on criminal data  the umbrella agreement sets protection  standards for personal data exchanged  between European and American  authorities fifty percent of EU citizens  use smartphones tablets or laptops to go  online Parliament is now working so that  people with digital subscriptions for  films music or books can access them  anywhere in the EU is how much the EU is  paid out since 2002 to repair the damage  from 70 to natural disasters across  Europe M ep's want to speed up the  relief response parliament approved the  European Union's 2017 budget nearly 6  billion euros of which will go to  migration and security issues and over  21 billion to boost growth and jobs from  now on cushion presidents have to cool  off for three years before taking  private sector jobs any PS also want the  financial interests of commissions to be  better disclosed in the future  [Music]